Xbox fans have a lot to get excited
about this year Microsoft released a new
console which pairs nicely with 4k HDR
TVs and there are new bundle options
we've rounded up the best accessories to
present you with GameSpot's Holiday Gift
Guide for the Xbox gamer I'm gonna start
off with the Xbox one X Microsoft
released this earlier this year and it
represents a more souped-up version of
the Xbox one it's got enough horsepower
to run games at 4k and HDR and will make
games look as good as they possibly can
it does cost $500 but it will give a
more expensive high-end PC a run for its
money
speaking of 4k TVs we're picking TCL's
55 p 605 55 inch TV not only this is a
sport 4k but it also supports HDR it
also comes with Roku support built right
in when you consider to the fact that
you can get this for around $600 that's
pretty unbelievable if you're looking
for a more affordable Xbox to gift this
holiday season we recommend the Xbox one
S which also has a couple bundles that
include games like Forza and minecraft
and more it's not as powerful as the
Xbox one X but it does support HDR and
cost less than half as much with game
installs getting bigger than ever
especially when you factor in large 4k
textures space is coming down to a
premium that's why we're recommending
Seagate's 2 terabyte game drive this
should be enough for most gamers the
Xbox one elite controller is arguably
the best game pad out there it comes
with 4 programmable paddles on the back
options to switch out the joysticks and
this kind of weird satellite looking
d-pad thing which works great for
fighting games it also comes with this
nifty carrying case it does cost $150
though so you really only should give it
to the most hardcore Xbox fan if you
don't feel like spending $150 on the
controller we totally understand you
could always just customize one on
Microsoft's Xbox design lab website
there are over 19 colors to choose from
and you can also customize the grips the
trigger buttons and more and for
additional fee you could engrave their
name or gamertag onto the controller on
the audio front we're gonna recommend
turtle beach's South 600 in addition to
sounding great they can sync up to the
expo
wirelessly without a dongle they're also
really comfortable and have a group for
glasses a safe bet for any Xbox gamer is
a 12-month subscription to Xbox Live
Gold it cost 60 bucks but it will allow
them to play online and it also comes
with free games each month so those were
our picks for the Xbox gamer for more
gift guides make sure to head on over to
GameSpot calm thank you for watching
[Music]